con is taking a [__] so I'm going to
talk to Joey about aliens for a sec Joey
do you like do you genuinely believe in
aliens because this like the question do
you believe in aliens I think it's a
very loaded question because most people
would say yes I believe there is other
life forms out there existing right now
but do you actually believe that one
they have reached a level of life and
Consciousness as some of the life you
see see cuz there's a difference between
believing in Aliens and believing in
extraterrestrial life right because
extraterrestrial life could be a super
[__] like highly highly uh you know
technologically advanced civilization
that is beyond our Wilders dreams to
something like a single- cell organism
right whereas when people think of
aliens they think of like oh like little
humanoid creatures that can communicate
like us and have a civilization like us
I don't I do I do believe that there are
aliens like of course like there are
like EXT terrestrial life out there
somewhere far out in the universe that
you know maybe has just as good if not
better civilization than else but I
think the more likely scenario is the
extraterrestrial life like the single
celled organisms or like you know the
the small creature equivalent of aliens
if you will I think those exist I would
even argue to say very close to our
proximity we just haven't found that yet
you know like the whole thing of like
you know how Mars originally had
evidence that there was water running
through it long ago in its history you
know we haven't explored enough of Mars
to know that but there is strong
evidence suggesting that there still
might be something there we just haven't
found also Europa as well which is
apparently
a mo jup moon right yeah yeah Jupiter's
moon that is uh has very strong evidence
that there is like a massive ocean yeah
like liquid underneath the ice sheets uh
which I find very interesting as well
totally but do you believe that there
are there is a higher life form of
aliens out
there yes I think there could be um I
just don't think they've come in contact
with humans I think they've like come
close to the Earth maybe but like that
whole idea of like you know [__] UFO
crash sites and stuff like that I don't
believe that [__] at all it's like how
incompetent of an alien species do you
have to be to fly like Galactic level
miles only for you to [__] up the
landing you know would care about us you
know I don't think they care about us I
think I think a to a lot of these aliens
the Earth is like a [__] Pebble on
the road to us yeah you know it's like
oh yeah it's there but I don't care yeah
kind of thing we're just expanding on
the alien uh do you want to know my
favorite Theory uh my favorite like
conspiracy kind of theory Sure so have
you heard of like super voids in the
universe no is it the [__] you watch
when you fall asleep yeah yeah pretty
much oh super like as in like areas of
space where there's nothing there yeah
yeah so there is just like huge [__]
areas of space uh so this is this goes
into like the whole structure of the
universe itself uh and there are like
you know the kind of like theory around
the Big Bang should say that everything
like on a theoretical level everything
should be pretty spread out pretty
evenly but how Galaxies have formed and
like the kind of structure of the
universe does not match up to the
theories that we with the big bang uh so
you have like [__] massive they call
them super voids which are some of the
biggest uh structures you can find in
the universe with yeah just massive
portions of this universe that are just
empty yeah it says it's a spherical blob
1.8 billion light years across that is
distinguished by its unusual emptiness
yeah and like one one of the theories
behind that is okay this is where it
gets through conspiracy theory time uh
is that there is a type three
civilization oh
my and that's why we do not detect
anything from there oh my Lord have they
have they sucked out all of the
nutrients out of the stars and they're
all just blinking out one by one yeah
yeah
exactly they made like the Dyson spheres
like the Dyson spher just sucking
wait
vacu just V okay my bad Dyson is when
they put like uh basically they just
build like a thing around a sun to
absorb all its energy oh I see have you
guys heard of have you guys heard of the
great attractor as well no what's that
so it's it's been it's been called me in
high
school no they [__] you were at a boy
High School Joey H yeah oh God it's been
proven that uh we are like there is this
portion of the universe that everything
is getting sucked towards and scientist
that's why they call it the greater
tractor and uh we can't we don't know
what is like causing a lot of like a
massive portion of like this universe to
get attracted to This One Singular point
because we can't see it cuz it's on the
opposite side of the Milky Way right
right uh so we just we just straight up
don't know we just okay we just straight
up don't know what the [__] could be
causing I love that thumbnail what is
that we're we're so off with everything
so all of these theories are plausible
cuz we just don't have enough proof to
disprove any of them right so but
obviously some more reasonable than
others either way let's move on to the
next one let's move on to the next one
Joey what are you presenting to us next
all right I've got a banger here okay
what is what is a theory that you
believe in a theory as a music lover as
as the only musician on trash taste
right this is a music theory right and I
believe it to be quite accurate okay
have you heard of uh they're kind of
like a small Indie band do you know this
band called The Beetles okay I'm aware
of them don't know if don't know if you
heard of them they're kind of they're
kind of small but there's a theory that
poses that that the famous British band
The Beatles never actually existed this
is this is the first time I'm hearing
[__] and that Paul McCartney John
lennin George Harrison and Ringo Star
were all just
actors okay okay that were also
interchangeable as they got older what
what were the what was the purpose of
acting a ban instead of being a ban it
was this big social experiment by the
government clearly by the British
government by the British
government the British government social
were they [__] YouTube pranksters way
back well they saw they saw how much you
know the American government was like
trolling Their audience so they like
their a even the civilization yeah yeah
yeah you know they they they were like
oh we got them good with the moon
landing and the British were like [__]
we want to do that what's big right now
oh yeah the beatle is are like a big ban
right now let's let's [__] him up so
there there are a number of uh theories
or I guess points to prove the theory
okay so first of all there are physical
appearance changes mhm okay so they
scrutinize photographs of the Beatles
over the years claiming that there are
inconsistencies in their appearance that
can't be explained by aging or changes
in style alone me can't be explained by
aing where is what do you [__] mean
what is this image I'm looking at right
now okay so say for example right George
Harrison on the left there where's his
other
ear what do you mean also that guy on
the right there is not Ringo
Star all paid actors okay you know your
your appearance you know this is going
to be a shock to some people your
appearance can change over time I don't
know if you know this yeah but the way
that they got older was a little bit
strange not not quite normal type in uh
on Google I want to show them uh type in
Robert dairo ears
change look how look how [__] much
this dude's ears have changed over the
years uh so ears are not a great look at
it the first one yeah look how much his
ears have changed holy [__] that's huge
age age is an unforgiving [__] godam so
your ears Robert isn't real okay
well prosthetic ear right there look at
that that's in fact young Robert Dair
actually played Paul McCartney okay all
right so the point is ears Ken jange so
saying that your ears change over time
yeah yeah yeah is proof is not even
remotely helpful to this argument okay
okay well there are also a bunch of
hidden messages as well right so have
you heard of have you heard of the
famous Paul is dead message no what is
this okay look up the Paul is dead
message I actually do what the pa is
dead message you know you know about
this one yeah I do know about this one
so the Paul is it's it's kind of like
another basically yeah look at the first
one there the Paul is
dead yeah so it's the theory that Paul
McCartney died years and years and years
ago like before John lennin died um and
because the way that he looks now and
especially after the Beatles ended is so
different to how he looked while the
Beatles article they have a picture of
him one year on the left and a year
later on the right and it looks a bit
different look at that that's not a year
of growth no but no cuz what is that
mustache I had this exact same thing uh
when I changed from a 720p camera to a a
4k camera I look significantly [__]
cuz I you could see how bad I looked and
I think that's what cuz like this is a
this is like a [__] oh we got our old
camera here where we found in our
basement we're got to take a picture of
Paul McCartney and then they take a
picture and then later some guys like
yeah with the new Sony CER
here the pi by the way Paul sorryim so
the Paul is dead Theory says that uh
Paul McCartney died uh aided by British
MI5 that's we had we had nothing better
going on in the it's the theory is that
he died in 1966 which was four years
before John lennin died uh and sorry no
seven years before John lennin died cuz
he died in 73 I believe if I remember
correctly um and that he was replaced by
an actor why didn't they replace John
Lennon as well then because the band was
probably just like [__] we can't find a
John no one is as good as John L I I
feel like the the solution to one of
your band mates passing is not to
replicate him they were like well it
worked with Paul and then when John died
they were like oh [__] we didn't we
didn't have a replacement
ready wait Paul MC PA MC's alive right
yes he's alive
or So currently So currently only John
Lennon and uh George Harrison are dead
Paul MC and I think Ringo is still alive
right or he could have been replaced as
well we don't know well Ringo they
probably wouldn't have been much demand
to replace him I
imagine poor poor Ringo my favorite uh
my favorite interview clip from the
Beatles is uh there was this there was
this uh interviewer who was like uh John
do you think that Ringo Star is the best
drummer in the world and John responds
he's not even the best drummer in the
band which is true so MI5 would have a
vested interest in helping Aid the bols
to replace Paul McCartney so there are
also claims that are made that the
personalities of the Beatles members as
observed in interviews and public
appearances show inconsistencies over
time too you could say that about
[__] trash T I was going to say I was
GNA say oh we replace [__]
Joey he watched Arcane he's a different
man now it's just not Joey is it uh
Conor admitted he likes beeps and boops
not the same that's like how on the
[__] podcast people are like oh KH
admitted a year later he liked something
trash T hasn't been the same since G
admitted his liking to bread you know
yeah like this is this is like Oh you
mean like normal change that happens
over time like yeah of course that
[__] personality changes yeah you're
not a monolith of a personality from age
10 to [__] as as a bunch of musicians
that the beatl were there was also skill
variation as well so the theory suggests
that there are noticeable variations in
the musical and songw writing skills of
the band members at different points in
their career allegedly indicating
different people with varying levels of
I can I can I can explain this one okay
uh
drugs
uh no
actually is that
your I mean listen they're musicians
right that I'm sure they were probably
doing some SK where they were probably
[__] no The Beatles having some party
nights going hard in the case with the
Beatles it is very obvious the era that
they discovered drugs because there was
a very big switch from like just simple
like standard rock tunes to like you
know [__] Yellow Submarine I am I
mean they were super successful you know
they became like the hottest [__] ever
they probably partying a bunch getting
super [__] like going out a bit a
bunch probably caring less about
songwriting a little bit because they
were focused on living the life that
they had acquired for themselves me at
that point as well John and Yoko were
together and they were getting a little
weird some people can just fall off yeah
some fall off and maybe they get back
into it maybe they don't you know John
had that whole Beatles fell
off this is that that that thing is just
that just sounds like the biggest copium
I can ever imagine in my life your
favorite band starts sucking you're like
guys the not real the original band is
dead they are not real why is it why is
it not plausible you could just get
worse for a period of time at something
oh yeah I mean it's like you know have
you ever done Exercise and then like one
day you go to the gym and you're like
[__] I'm just terrible at exercise today
though I've I've been doing this for
ages like you're just going to have days
where you're off what other evidence do
you without a lick of irony um and being
a massive Beatles fan uh this theory is
incredibly stupid uh I agree with
everything it's just like yeah the way
that you grow and change as a musician
is very different for different people
and just some people you know I I hate
the fact that there are so many people
out there out there who are like Yeah
The Beatles were like the peak of Music
creativity like they they were the
[__] masters of their craft I'm like
yeah they were good musicians but they
didn't like [__] you know change it
reinvent the wheel part of me wants to
believe that this specifically this
theory is just a
meme I would like to hope it's a mem I
really want to hope it's a meme oh yeah
there's the there's the Magical Mystery
Tour that was the album where they
clearly started doing
drugs I mean look at that
cover yeah yeah part of me wants to
believe I'm I'm reading through all of
these points part of me wants to believe
that this is just the meme and because
of the modern conspiracy theory kind of
like oh yeah the other theory of the
pole is dead
theory is that on the ab Road cover Paul
is the only one not wearing
shoes he's a
ghost why why would why would a ghost be
concerned about Footwear exactly it's
the moon landing all that's why that's
why he's not wearing shoes cuz he's
actually already dead it's the symbolism
in there symbolism Paul is holding his
cigarette in his right hand even though
he's left-handed in what yeah and he's
not wearing shoes explain
that what do you mean explain that he's
dead okay or he's been replaced by
someone who clearly didn't realize that
Paul McCartney wears shoes everywhere
and holds a cigarette in his left I wear
shoes everywhere if I took my [__]
shoes off for one [__] occasion
wouldn't mean I I'm a [__] ghost I
don't know say that to Australians
bro we walk around with shoes all the
time I don't know I feel like this one I
can see how this conspiracy theory
started um do you think this was started
by Beatles fans or Beatles haters um I
think this isy both are plausible
plausible um I don't even think the
Beatles is something that is a unique
topic um it's pretty a wh if that got
out of hand I feel yeah yeah yeah I feel
like it's just a wh if that just got out
of hands just because the Beatles got so
popular uh and it's not I mean this is
one this is one step away from you know
ninja dying from ligma you
know you know you know like ninja di of
ligma he's been replaced I feel like it
was like a joke that one person took
seriously and then it just kind of got
widespread if that if I had to pinpoint
it's all fun in games until the obituary
comes out exactly exactly I'm not sure
when this Theory started but guaranteed
if this Theory started in the age of the
internet I I have a feeling it would
just have been like one massive Meme and
yeah yeah I mean like you know at the
end of this uh article here as well that
makes a good point of like this I feel
like this also came out around the time
where like rock music in general was you
know have had all these conspiracies of
like oh they're brainwashing the use
with satanic messages and it's the
devil's music and all that kind of stuff
right so this Theory might have stemmed
from there um or it could have just
stemmed from a a hardcore Beatles hater
or hardcore Beatles fan just being like
all right but what if you know this this
is the only way we can explain the
Beatles falling off yeah I mean I I see
all of this proof and uh this doesn't
even seem like that deep of a psych
analysis as you get of some YouTube
drama you know you know what I mean you
you see YouTubers like or like you know
twitch streamers have drama and you see
people psychoanalyzing mic analyzing
everything I'm like this this is this
doesn't even seem that out of the realm
of possibility as some of the stuff we
see today it also says the belief that
the music industry or other powerful
entities the government orchestrated
this deception for financial gain or
other unknown purposes well you've
convinced me Joey as soon as you said
the government all right wake up she
it's the British government this time go
the Brits I don't know I see out of
everything this is the most lukewarm
Theory I don't even think it's that
interesting of a theory I'm I'm giving
this zero this one's just dumb yeah just
if you don't like the Beatles it's fine
you can just say you don't like the
Beatles All Right fair enough